Приветствую, с вами Вектор Т13.
В наших прошлых уроках мы рассмотрели множество различных отпечатков, которые мы можем найти,
и мы рассмотрели их под совершенно другим углом.
Не только лишь по проверке хэша, например, и так далее,
а непосредственно, как эти технологии могут использоваться не только для фингерпринтинга,
но и для определения виртуальных машин, а также ВПС-серверов или удаленных серверов.
И сейчас настало время одной технологии, которую наверняка вы слышали,
но не совсем понимаете, для чего она используется.
Итак, технология WebGL.
Вы скажете, мы про нее уже говорили? Безусловно.
Но мы обязаны о ней упомянуть.
Дело в том, что WebGL — это технология,
которая уже не поддерживается.
То есть, иными словами, она не будет развиваться.
В том виде, в котором она есть, она больше никакого развития не получит.
Есть такая компания, которая называется
Kronos Group WebGL.
Kronos Group — это объединение, которое создало такой стандарт, как WebGL.
WebGL-1, WebGL-2.
Если вам это интересно, можете сюда зайти и почитать, что конкретно они сделали.
Так вот, они в 2023 году заявили, что больше не будет никакой работы производиться над WebGL.
Технология устарела, и в первую очередь она устарела архитектурно.
Ну, что ожидать от технологии, которая с нами была на протяжении более чем 10 лет.
Понятно, что она может устареть.
И на ее смену, на смену технологии WebGL,
приходит технология, про которую наверняка вы уже слышали.
Эта технология называется WebGPU.
Технология WebGPU, несмотря на свою инновативность,
на текущий момент все равно находится еще в экспериментальной фазе.
Данная технология, ее основная фишка заключается в том,
что она предоставляет веб-ресурсу доступ к видеокарте,
и вот здесь есть как и плюсы, так и минусы.
Плюсы заключаются в том, что у пользователя есть возможность буквально,
представьте себе, играть в игры Steam, не устанавливая их на компьютер,
а просто с помощью веб-ресурса.
Ну, условно говоря, вот это работает таким образом.
То есть настолько быстрая, настолько прорывная технология,
которая позволяет использовать все ресурсы видеокарты в браке,
в браузере, но в то же время, такая сила, она также является большой ответственностью.
Поэтому нехорошие люди могут использовать это все для майнинга, например,
кстати, майнинг через веб-страницы, я еще такое с 2013 года помню,
тогда майнили с помощью WebGL.
Также это может использоваться для выполнения вредоносного кода на компьютере пользователя
и заражения его браузером.
Например, это может использоваться для DirectX-инъекции и множество-множество всего.
Ну а сейчас мы будем говорить только лишь о том, что интересует нас.
Прошу обратить внимание, в данном случае у меня используется одна из последних версий браузера Chrome.
Давайте посмотрим, какая версия у меня используется.
У меня используется 138-я версия, не последняя, потому что Chrome сейчас захочет обновиться еще.
Так вот.
Раньше была возможность...
...даже определить, какая модель видеокарты используется на компьютере пользователя.
Сейчас же есть возможность определить, поддерживает ли браузер WebGPU и кто является производителем данной видеокарты.
Фактически, на этом все.
Остальные моменты, которые у нас здесь касаются константа, обработки графики, дополнительных возможностей,
они нас на данный момент не интересуют, потому что рассказывать про них это очень скучно, нудно и так далее.
Если мы посмотрим...
Если мы посмотрим наш JSON Dump, то мы увидим только лишь видеокарту Nvidia и архитектуру ее.
Все.
Девайс у нас, к сожалению, пустой.
Не вот этот девайс, а вот этот девайс.
Вот, он у нас пустой.
Поэтому на текущий момент непонятно, почему Chrome так сделал.
Возможно, они считают это каким-либо нарушением, либо же препятствуют какому-либо очередному вектору атак и так далее.
Нас это сейчас не волнует.
Каким образом WebGPU может использоваться на текущий момент в антифрауд системах?
Вот, что нас интересует.
И здесь есть два основных момента.
Первый момент. Наличие WebGPU.
Наличие WebGPU, вот этого флажка, то, что ваш браузер поддерживает WebGPU, это, конечно, хорошо.
Вы увидите это во всех современных браузерах.
Но не везде вы увидите, что у вас идет поддержка вашей видеокарты.
То есть WebGPU.
Дело в том, что в зависимости от вашей видеокарты браузер сам может принять решение, разрешать вам технологию WebGPU или нет.
Это первое.
Второе. Браузер, сам браузер Chrome, может принять решение на основании того, какой уровень DirectX поддерживает ваша видеокарта.
Если ваша видеокарта не поддерживает DirectX 12,
то, соответственно,
вам не дадут возможности использовать технологию WebGPU.
Поэтому, если вдруг вы увидите на таких вот абсолютно конченных и припизденных, по-другому не могу назвать их,
тестах, как вот fingerprint.com, никогда не переходите на этот сайт.
Поверьте, это просто, это идиотизм и кал.
Если будет интересно, я расскажу в следующих уроках.
Но, вот если мы сейчас пойдем.
Вот они, в частности, Detect виртуальной машины,
они, знаете, как проверяют виртуальную машину?
Поддерживается ли WebGPU или нет?
То есть, иными словами, вы можете просто у себя в браузере Chrome перейти на вкладку Chrome Flex
и в поиске WebGPU можете включить WebGPU, вот здесь вот Enabled.
И после этого вы обойдете Detect якобы виртуальной машины.
Вот.
Но я не зря об этом упомянул.
Дело в том, что если ваша видеокарта поддерживает максимально уровень DirectX 11 и не поддерживает DirectX 12,
то, соответственно, у вас и поддержки WebGPU быть не может быть.
А вот, например, антифрод-система fingerprint.com будет думать, что вы являетесь пользователем виртуальной машины.
Почему же я говорю, что это плохой метод Detect?
Дело в том, что fingerprint.com, в данном случае,
является ничем иным, как ханипотом.
Никто в своем здравом уме не будет посещать данный веб-ресурс просто так, ради интереса.
Будут посещать его люди, которые хотят проверить свою анонимность и так далее.
В частности, в чатах в Telegram я очень резко отзывался о людях, которые переходили на данный веб-ресурс.
И потом еще говорили, ух, а у меня тут видно VPN, например, у меня тут видно еще что-то.
У меня тут видно виртуальная машина.
Я говорю, ну вот, ходи и смотри теперь, раз ты такой.
Суть. Одного лишь наличия веб-GPU мало.
Я вам расскажу, в чем прикол.
Дело в том, что мы можем эмулировать наличие веб-GPU через реестр.
Элементарно просто.
Если у нас идет поддержка VDDM,
то есть, сейчас покажу, что это такое.
Вот мы запускаем утилиту под названием DXDiag.
И здесь на вкладке Pro Display мы видим вот Driver Model, VDDM.
Если у нас этот VDDM больше, чем версия 2.3,
ну, например, наша видеокарта не поддерживает DirectX 12,
то уровни поддержки номинальные.
Вы можете добавить элементарно просто через реестр.
Как это сделать?
Спросите у чата GPT, например.
Либо же просто найдите в реестре свойства вашей видеокарты.
Добавьте туда то, что вы хотите.
И после этого вы получите вашу видеокарту якобы с DirectX 12.
После этого вы сразу же получите веб-GPU.
Как пример.
Почему я объяснил вот этот пример?
Дело в том, что методик, по которым можно эмулировать наличие видеокарты в веб-GPU,
их довольно много.
Можно подменить видеокарту в самом браузере с помощью подмены ответа на свойства навигатора GPT.
Можно подменить через реестр.
Можно воспользоваться различными другими утилитами для того, чтобы это осуществить.
Суть.
Антифрод-системы не используют проверку веб-GPU.
То, что вы видели на сайте fingerprint.com, является идиотизмом.
И еще раз повторюсь, ханипотом для того, чтобы собрать ваши остальные данные.
Как же реально используется веб-GPU для того, чтобы проверить, существует оно или нет?
Та-дам!
Это бенчмарк.
Точно так же, как мы проводили с вами бенчмарк веб-GL, Canvas, Audio,
точно так же можно провести бенчмарк веб-GPU.
А, соответственно, переходя на вот этот веб-ресурс, исходник которого вы можете найти на GitHub,
нажав на кнопочку Run,
вы можете посмотреть реальные показатели вашей видеокарты.
А, соответственно, если вы используете, например, дискретную видеокарту,
это будет здесь видно.
Если вы используете поддельные значения видеокарты,
это здесь будет видно.
Если вы захотите с помощью вашего антидетект-браузера,
в котором у вас есть поддержка, якобы, веб-GPU и подмена,
показать, что у вас есть видеокарта,
это здесь будет видно.
Благодаря данному тесту есть возможность определения,
как, первое, использования VPS,
VPS с антидетектом,
удаленных серверов,
удаленных серверов с антидетектом,
то есть, dedicated server, я имею в виду.
Так же есть возможность определения использования встроенных видеокарт,
иными словами, если вы, например, ваша встроенная видеокарта,
она поддерживает DirectX 12,
но вы, например, имея видеокарту Intel встроенную,
заявляете, что у вас видеокарта 4090, дискретная Nvidia.
По показателям это будет видно,
что вы используете поддельную видеокарту.
Таким образом, благодаря веб-GPU бенчмарку,
есть возможность идентификации антидетектов,
есть возможность идентификации использования удаленных сетевых ресурсов,
использования удаленных сетевых ресурсов.
И по факту вам скажу так,
что производительность видеокарты в данном случае
намного точнее, чем производительность веб-GL.
И если, например, использование веб-GL,
когда мы помним с вами 136, 138 FPS,
разницы между, например,
2080, 1080 и 3080,
никакой не будет,
то в случае использования веб-GPU
на основе статистических данных
есть возможность реально определить,
что используется видеокарта второго семейства,
первого семейства, третьего семейства или четвертого семейства.
Происходит это как раз по той причине,
что имеется полный доступ к ресурсам видеокарты,
а, соответственно, есть возможность на полный проверить,
как она отрабатывает в данном случае.
И если мы с вами сейчас попытаемся произвести небольшой тест,
давайте мы запустим тест Performance,
и вот мы видим видеокарту.
В данном случае у меня как раз тоже используется
и встроенная видеокарта, и дискретная видеокарта.
И мы сейчас попробуем инициировать
веб-GPU проверку.
Результат вас удивит.
Возможно, мы абсолютно ничего не увидим.
Кто знает? Посмотрим сейчас.
Итак, нажимаем наш тест Run.
Посмотрите на график.
Вот я сейчас хочу показать, где у нас, вот оно, 3D.
Мы видим всплеск активности.
Давайте попробуем сейчас не 10 миллионов,
например, а 50 миллионов.
По-моему, у нас от такой нагрузки даже...
Да нет, validation failed.
У нас даже браузер не выдержал такой загрузки.
Давайте попробуем 20 миллионов.
Нет, к сожалению, даже, видите,
из-за огромного количества ресурсов даже падает браузер.
Но, по крайней мере, мы можем увидеть этот запрос веб-GPU на графике.
Почему я говорю, что мы можем увидеть, а можем не увидеть?
Дело в том, что здесь зависит от того количества элементов,
которые будут использоваться на веб-странице тестере.
Если мы, например, возьмем 100 тысяч.
Давайте посмотрим сейчас.
Результат у нас 221, 393, 958.
Ну, здесь у нас при 100 тысячах
результаты намного меньше.
И, как мы видим, на графике никаких изменений нет.
То есть, вот давайте еще раз проведем этот тест.
100 тысяч сэмплов всего-навсего.
Никаких особых всплесков у нас нет.
Давайте перейдем выше.
До 200 тысяч сэмплов.
Всплесков нет.
Может быть, 500 тысяч?
Никаких всплесков нет.
Миллион.
Никаких.
Два миллиона.
Два миллиона показали уже определенную активность.
И на это я хочу обратить ваше внимание.
Дело в том, что мы могли определить, например,
когда у нас использовался веб-GL тест.
Мы можем даже в теории определить, когда используется тест веб-GPU.
Но, к сожалению, это можно определить только,
если используется действительно большое количество сэмплов для рендеринга.
Как в нашем случае.
Вот до 2 миллионов мы даже не ощущали на нашей видеокарте каких-либо нагрузок.
А если мы будем использовать с вами, например,
видеокарту не такую старую, как использую я,
а будем использовать видеокарту последнего поколения,
как 4090, к примеру,
или 5090 уже серия, наверное, есть.
То там даже всплески на 10 миллионов,
они не будут заметны вообще никаким образом.
То есть график будет абсолютно ровный, без каких-либо колебаний.
Почему на это стоит обратить внимание?
Дело в том, что если вы хотите произвести анализ того,
что веб-ресурс использует технологию веб-GPU бенчмарка,
у вас есть два варианта, как это сделать.
Первый вариант – запустите маломощную видеокарту,
как в моем случае, например, вот встроенная видеокарта Radeon.
Запустите браузер с помощью данной видеокарты.
И тогда вы сможете уловить даже мельчайшие колебания,
которые есть на веб-ресурсе.
Ну и второй метод, он является намного сложнее.
Делаем вот таким вот образом.
Правой кнопкой мышки – View Page Source.
Здесь на основной странице ищем, но не находим.
Navigator.
Ничего не нашли.
Поэтому переходим на Benchmark.js.
Navigator.
И видим опцию Navigator WebGPU.
Навигатор просто GPU.
Если мы видим данный флаг,
то это означает, что данный веб-ресурс использует технологию WebGPU.
Однако в некоторых случаях, конечно же,
мы можем столкнуться с обфускацией JavaScript-кода,
и это не будет заметно.
Поэтому самым лучшим вариантом,
если вы подозреваете, что веб-ресурс может использовать GPU-бенчмарк,
это использовать маломощную видеокарту
для того, чтобы уловить даже малейшие колебания,
которые могут от вас потребовать.
В моем случае, кстати, видеокарта Radeon
здесь поддерживает DirectX 12 версии,
так что она полностью поддерживает и технологию WebGPU.
И, соответственно, благодаря ее малой мощности,
всего-навсего в 512 мегабайт,
мы можем определить, когда эта память
будет заполнена полностью.
Спасибо за внимание.
С вами был VectorT13.